welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is hon saucy the Byrd White House and
professor of comparative literature at
Yale University professor saucy has a
range of scholarly interest including
Chinese poetry literature aesthetics and
culture his published articles explore a
wide range of topics such as Chinese
musicology the history of the idea of
oral literature Haitian literature
health care for the poor and
contemporary art in his first book the
problem of a Chinese aesthetic he
applied a new model of comparative
literature and in his book great walls
of discourse and other adventures in
cultural China he examines the way that
assumptions and consensus within a
discipline affect collective thinking
about the object of study today we'll
talk with Professor saucey about
comparative literature
welcome professor saucey thank you let's
begin with the basics what is
comparative literature how did the field
emerge in contrast to English say or
rhetoric sure comparative literature the
term emerges around 1820 in the wake of
Napoleon's conquest of Europe which as
you know was rapidly rolled back but
what what spurred it I think is that
people begin to talk about cultural and
national difference and previously I
think the models for culture had all
come from ancient Greece and Rome and
the idea was that neoclassical art was
good enough for everybody
and people were trying to catch up with
the people who had the best neoclassical
art which were of course the French but
as kind of as a cultural resistance to
the Napoleonic conquests people in the
conquered areas like Germany Italy and
so forth began to discover that they
they were not just waiting around to be
discovered as dormant Frenchmen but that
they they did things differently their
linguistic differences their
historical differences were important to
them and so literature becomes plural
after after Napoleon in Europe anyway
hence the the idea of needing to compare
and contrast and emphasize the
differences so I think comparative
literature always grows out of a
realization of differences in the u.s.
it got its big start after the Second
World War I think because in this
country we began to participate on an
international stage and it's more or
less contemporary with the creation of
area studies which is why I think it's
appropriate for me to be talking about
comparative literature in a Macmillan
Center format because why area studies
is is what we live on here in McMillan
and complet would you're in in this
version of things comparative literature
would be sort of the the artistic and
literary side of this awareness that
there are a lot of cultures out there
that they don't all reduce down to one
model and that what's interesting about
them is how they how they differ so how
do you make it work then well this is
the trick because you can you can just
say this you know this culture is like
that culture this author is like that
author this work is like that work but
it's not it's not really interesting
unless you also take the theoretical
step back and say where do I get my
judgment of similarity or of difference
here what are the historical connections
how does my position as an observer
affect the things that I'm going to
notice and observe so in that for me is
where the excitement is I mean of course
it's great to be able to simply compare
but also you want to stand aside from
yourself and watch yourself compare that
must be hard to do and so much
subjective I imagine do you have any
difficulty along those lines I've my
secret is to make my work out of my
difficulty right some friend of mine
likes to say you need to find a job that
mirrors your personal pathology this
happens to be the kind of difficulty
that interests me the most
reflexive nough some something in
addition to ourselves by thinking about
ourselves and so I hope it's it's a
feature and not a bug
in the comparative mindset I am curious
in terms of your personal history and
how you became attracted or how did you
find comparative literature what drew
you to it it was it was accidents I was
a freshman in college trying to write an
essay about participles and prepositions
there was something that bothered me
about both of those things in language I
was always drawn to linguistics and I
was a Greek major as an undergraduate so
I was just trying to think about how
language relates to thought and some
people sent me to some books and I read
them I wasn't so sure and I stumbled
across this book by the anthropologist
Claude lévi-strauss called
the savage mind and it just completely
opened doors for me and made me think
about cultures as as being very tightly
organized bodies of knowledge that makes
sense on their own basis and may not
translate into other cultures now later
on I thought that was a very incomplete
way of thinking about it
but you know it's as if I just
discovered a whole range of other
planets to explore you've written a book
called comparative literature in an era
of globalization what was the catalyst
to writing the book and tell us a little
bit about it sure the catalyst was was
very empirical the American comparative
literature Association has a mandate in
their bylaws that every 10 years
somebody has to write a report on the
state of comparative literature and they
asked me to do it
I hesitated because I didn't want to
write the report because I didn't I
didn't think I was the only person who
had something to say so I did eat up the
responsibility and had other people make
contributions from their very different
points of view and then we had yet other
people reflect on the contributions of
those first contributors but since I got
to be the editor I hogged some space and
I wrote the first and longest piece
where I just talked about how I thought
the the field had been developing in the
last really the last half century but
particularly the last 10 years and one
move that I noticed was from an idea of
comparative literature as
multiculturalism
where each culture as I was saying just
a moment ago right this model of each
culture being sort of like a planet that
spins on its own axis to attention to
things that cover a lot of different
cultures that you might call
globalization right so multiculturalism
would tend to make us isolate cultures
and think of cultures as having their
own constituencies and their own ways of
being and a force like globalization
think of it as economic globalization or
the the mobility of Labor for example
today that we see in the economic world
these are these are like tsunamis
they're like big waves that cover
everything in their path and there are
such things if you're only interested in
the multicultural angle of difference
you might be oblivious to these big
dynamics and yet how does the big
universal dynamic intersect with the way
that we comparative literature people
focus on difference in specificity that
was what was interesting to me and how
does it well we we exhibit this relation
I think in some of the things that we
pay attention to fifteen years ago
people were not paying attention to
things like world literature which has
since grown up to be a big obsession of
many people in the field and what it
what is world literature it's the the
traffic among nations that causes some
authors to become prominent on a global
scale and of courses have been going on
for a long time almost 200 years ago
Goethe named world literate Ori said
that the age of world literature is
coming and he could be a good example of
it because by the time he died everybody
on the planet who read works of
literature knew about Goethe right other
writers might not have had such a
promising beginning but they grow to
have worldwide significance you know
people like Baudelaire let's say who was
censored in his home country but maybe
because of that became
the dominant poet of the modern world or
people like Fernando Pessoa a Portuguese
poet who just make things more
complicated rodents under several
pseudonyms he too enters circulation
people translate him he's published in
different countries and people respond
to him so the people who work on world
literature are interested in these
mechanisms of circulation right how does
how does a book get an audience beyond
its immediate language or its immediate
nation and culture and so they they
chart this kind of dynamic you work in
the field of comparative literature and
you specialize in Chinese literature how
do the two intersect for you will with
difficulty Bria as you know I love
difficulty and the hard part is getting
these two things to translate into each
other in what I think about the way
literary cultures develop I think China
would maybe be the type case of what you
could call a normal development that is
literature is from very early on
sponsored by a strong state apparatus
that uses literature and literary
culture as a means of recruiting people
everybody knows about the famous
Mandarin exams where people thousands of
people all over the country would take
these standardized exams every three
years to compete for a place in the
bureaucracy and the way that you showed
that you had talent was by literary
writing there were poetry entries for
example along with the essay entries on
the exams so the ability to wield
literary language and to do really
intelligent things with with the whole
past of Chinese literature became a
major qualifier for being an important
person in that culture I would not say
that that's the way literature works in
the United States of America in the year
2010 many of the most brilliant
rhetorician
I know are unemployed people who write
the best novels often have a very hard
time going from month to month so we
we're in what from the point of view of
traditional China might be an abnormal
state the other thing that strikes me in
Chinese literature is the continuity of
it all you can if you're literate in
Chinese you can pick up a document from
the age of Homer
and more or less understand what it's
about you might need some some help with
some of the hard words but there's a lot
of continuity you know continuity of
language continuity of culture and of
meanings well try reading a sample of
English from just 500 years ago and you
know how difficult it can be Europe and
European traditions generally are all
about turnover it seems every few
hundred years the dominant language in
Europe will switch institutions change
you have church and university and state
and civil society and the market and all
these things
each pushing their own modes of
communication their own languages their
own canons as we say in the literary
field and in China things are much more
neatly harmonized around a central core
of things that everybody expects to know
so if China's normal and Europe's
abnormal and abnormal doesn't mean bad
in my vocabulary
abnormal abnormal correlates with
interesting vocabulary but if if they
have such such deeply different ways of
organizing the cultural world then the
comparison becomes interesting because
it can't just be point four point you
can't just be comparing the poet Li
Xiang nian with the poet Rambo but it
involves the whole structure of culture
that there each part how do you do that
ah well one trick is to pay a lot of
attention to context and then they have
to compensate for the fact that since
the context is so different you're
you're not going to be dealing with a
lot of similarity so you tend to have to
say things like the way that this poet
reacts to that tradition is similar to
the way the other poet reacts to the
different tradition over on this side so
it becomes a little bit more Russia che
to use good English it becomes a little
bit more twisty and devious but but I
think the the comparisons that result
are not just ingenious you know a lot of
us are good at being ingenious but often
they're very meaningful because I think
you can extract from these situations
some basic categories like resistance
rethinking rewriting
the the job of digging up lost ancestors
you know people who thought like you
from maybe 600 years ago and were
ignored at the time and suddenly become
vital for your culture at another moment
you know these kinds of dynamic I think
are pretty widespread if we know how to
look for them and do you think language
plays a large role in comparative
literature we do you need to be a
linguist for instance you you need to be
unafraid of languages I think you have
you have to you have to have a realistic
standard for your ability to deal with
languages because if you're dealing with
say six or seven languages which is not
an abnormal number for comparative
literature
you're not going to speak all of them
like a native maybe you can get up to
native level with one language other
than your own they're going to be a lot
of languages where you're using plenty
of duct tape and baling wire to get your
ideas across nonetheless if you're if
you're willing to engage with languages
not be afraid of your tendency to fall
over your feet you can you can deal with
with them and I think here's one region
one area where comparative literature
I think differs a little bit from the
world literature framework because world
literature is interested in translation
but translation is always the vehicle to
get the content moved over to a new
place where it can have new readers
comparative literature throughout its
whole history has been attentive to
specific languages in my advanced
classes I want people to read text in
the original and be able to pay
attention to that level of detail where
its word choice its semantics its even
things like alliteration and rhyme that
have a powerful influence on how you're
going to receive a text so I think
language is one thing that we absolutely
can't throw out the window and still be
doing comparative literature seems like
it would make it very difficult to
though if you have to know several
different languages to be to be good at
it yeah when I sent my first book to the
press it was just packed with all these
quotations and foreign languages because
because I was a young pipsqueak I was
coming up in the world and I thought I
have to show these people that I know my
stuff
my editor sent back a note and said with
every foreign language quotation you
lose half of the readership you had up
until then so so I did the math and by
page 8 I was down to a readership of
about 0.4 that's that so with the with
less than one reader I thought kind of
changed this so I made the book more
user friendly I translated all the
quotations and and with the step that
you have to go to to have the reader but
nonetheless I think the reason for doing
that is to tell people is to show people
this is worth doing it is so much more
fun if you can read this stuff on your
own so accept my offer of temptation and
come into the palace of comparative what
do you think the future holds for
comparative literature where do you
think it's going well one thing that
happens is that languages that were less
studied become more studied right look
at the number of people who are studying
Chinese in Arabic for example in this
country I worry that people are studying
those languages only up to communicative
ability I hope that people go on and
study the classical version of the
languages read widely become culturally
literate so that it's not just a matter
of communicating or understanding or so
the worst case scenario is that people
learn just enough language in order to
read a document for a very defined
purpose my mental pictures of people
sitting with earphones on their heads in
a basement in Langley Virginia
having learned Arabic just in order to
do intelligence intersects I think that
would be a waste of human talent so if
people go on and and study the
literature and the culture and become
very deeply fluent they can make real
contributions to comparative literature
and I also think there's an element of
that elusive thing that we call
international understanding that would
be achieved in that way right I admire
people who can walk into different
cultures and make themselves at home and
get across whatever message they have
without seeming to do it from a from an
alien standpoint where they're imposing
their ideas but they're sort of
eliciting the latent ideas in that
culture that happened to harmonize with
the ideas that they had on their own
do admire that as well yes well thank
you so much for being here with us today
and sharing some of your work Thank You
Marilyn it's been a pleasure for more
information about Professor saucy and
his work please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you